Okay, so tomorrow is my birthday. Yay!
But I, like many people on the internet,
do not identify with my chronological age,
and that if I were to become pregnant tomorrow,
there is no doubt in my mind that I would be a statistic.
I would be a teen mom.
All of this, it has a name,
and it's called Millennial Imposter Syndrome.
And it's where you look at your body and you look at your life,
and you're like,
there is no way that when my parents were this age,
this is what raised me.
So while other generations have a fear of aging,
we. We feel like we're too young for our age.
Some upsides. Um,
like, our skin is amazing.
Apparently. People can't stop talking about it,
but they're also big financial and economic pressures
and reasons why millennials have been
doing so less well than their parents.
So, yeah,
I wrote about it for SUBSAC.
You can go subscribe. Uh,
as my birthday gift.
Let me know how you feel about aging.
Do you feel like it differs, um,
for every generation with your relationship to it?
Let's talk about it.